foreign
[Music]
this one looks like he's giving me the
thumbs up
so do you have a lab partner yet
is there a Chim Wang here well this is
Wayne Chang waitan he's a new student
and he's Chinese like you he's gonna tag
along to all of your classes
except Mass
he's way ahead of you in math I just
want to be a regular guy who does
regular stuff you made a new friend
I just thought this here is gonna be
different
[Music]
I may be able to help
what's going on I'm not from this world
and I need your help with my quest to
stop the uprising
gate between Earth and Heaven's opening
okay
you must stop it or everyone will perish
the fate of Your World hangs in the
balance I don't really see how I fit
into this whole thing from my guide
was something a little bit cooler than
kaid servant yeah I know you're right
guys better
it will be difficult and dangerous what
do you thinking about what if I'm not
though
fate is not decided up there but down
here
everything is more connected than you
think
yay
[Music]